jouy-en-josas à l'ouest de paris le lieu
traditionnel de rassemblement de
l'équipe de france avant ses rendez vous
importants des rendez vous importants
comme l'euro 84 les hommes du
sélectionneur michel hidalgo ont
construit leur victoire européenne sur
deux terrains à jouy en josas au sein du
campus de l'école de commerce hec et sur
le stade municipal jean-claude hamon et
ifs pignon deux anciens joueurs du club
local ont des souvenirs des
infrastructures et parce que ça c'est
l'entraînement c'est un tout petit local
arbitres si les lions ont changé
aujourd'hui les souvenirs restent
intactes ex dirigeants de l'ue s jouy en
josas jans lomani à conserver des photos
des joueurs de l'époque
alors ça c'est des photos de l'équipe de
france
bonnet rouge tour didier six à tignes à
michel platini encore six rocheteau des
stars de l'époque janvion tigana lors
d'une interview que j'avais fait à
l'hôtel val de bièvre j'avais mais je
faisais un journal à l'époque pour le
club de foot local et j'avais demandé à
faire une interview novembre 1981 les
français jouent leur qualification à la
coupe du monde contre les pays-bas au
parc des princes boulanger à l'époque
jean claude hamon se souvient avoir reçu
une commande de la directrice de l'hôtel
où résidaient les bleus allaient faire
un gâteau un petit peu rapidement parce
qu'elle est venue me voir le dimanche
pour lundi soir était fermée le lundi
et puis ils ont gagné
le gâteau ils ont elles en main le
bateau était dans l'équipe
voyez les mecs en train de rigoler quoi
boire un coup avec le gâteau et le
gâteau dans le parisien pour parier à
l'époque entre la fed va commencer à
minuit elle se terminera très tôt ce
matin
ce n'est pas il est vrai toutes les
nuits concept la qualification il y
avait du monde et puis puisque les très
bons enfants quoi surtout c'était les
gens ils rentraient se mettre autour
d'un mât exactement à partir de 1988
l'équipe de france installe à
clairefontaine la commune devient alors
le centre technique national du football
français à jouy en josas le football
continue de faire vibrer les amateurs du
ballon rond